new data suggests that summer may help
tamp down coronavirus President Trump
and Chris Cuomo's wife both have some
interesting medical suggestions and
Congress continues to vomit out money
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN you have a right to
privacy protected and expressive VPN
calm / man that's expressed VPN calm /
Ben alrighty so I definitely do want to
get to everything corona virus medical
medical suggestion related but let's be
honest about this this is all stupid
okay like it's seriously seriously
stupidly people focusing in on Trump's
sort of John Belushi esque rantings from
Animal House about medical solutions
because he sort of understands and he
sort of doesn't think that that is not
what people should be putting their
focus right now how about putting our
focus on the fact that like our food
supply chains are in a bit of trouble I
mean the fact is that farmers are
plowing under crop because they can't
make money from selling that crop at a
time when food shortages would probably
mean riots in the streets restaurants
which were providing a huge market for
all of our agriculture those are those
restaurants aren't going under an
incredibly rapid rates that means
they're probably gonna be seeing more
expensive products on a shelf at a time
when people have less money to spend
it's a real real problem right that's
something we should think about we
should be thinking about how are we
supposed to reopen in an environment in
which the data are so uncertain and
we'll talk about that in a little bit
what the media are focused on is
continuing to be the gotcha game of
President Trump said something dumb at a
press conference and okay
I mean alright I suppose but but if you
really believe that that is of vital
importance then you're out of your mind
and this is the same media that
suggested that President Trump by
recommending hydroxychloroquine as
impossible as a possible treatment for
kovin 19 that he forced a woman to feed
her husband fish tank cleaner and then
the guy died and the media like that's
trumps poem which is a pretty fantastic
way of creating an alibi for murdering
your husband not saying she murdered her
husband but if you were going to murder
your husband and then have the media
establish an alibi would there be a
better way to do it
let the Carol basket a fish tank cleaner
over here let's start with actual news
and then we will get to all of the
pseudo controversy today over president
Trump and Clorox and whether you can
ingest sunlight whether you can actually
just eat a ball of some light and it
will actually fix everything yes we've
now reached the stupid part right it
always takes a little while for serious
stories to become incredibly stupid it
took us about five weeks
for an incredibly serious story to turn
into just full-scale utter stupidity
that sort of at the outside I mean the
fish tank cleaner story was a couple
weeks ago and that was real done but
what we are now reaching new lows first
let's bring you some actual useful
information so I had some questions
about this whole corona virus knowledge
level nobody seems to know anything
I mean seriously no one seems to know
what the hell is going on with this
thing I say this because there's an
article out today suggesting that
two-thirds of seriously ill kovat 19
patients even have a fever
like at all like did not have a fever so
you've been told they're gonna have a
fever for like a week if you got Cove in
nineteen and that is one of the first
symptoms you should look out for we
should be doing temperature tests at the
doors of our major businesses and it
turns out that yeah that thing mhm
according to ABC News a new study is
presenting surprising findings about
Cove in nineteen and which factors play
the biggest role in how severe the
disease is for some people with New York
being in the epicenter for the virus in
the United States Reacher's for
researchers from the state's largest
healthcare system quickly moved to
document findings that would help
identify others and treat Cove in 19
patients one thing stood out in the
study published in the Journal of
American medicine a senior researcher
karina davidson she says the most
surprising finding was two-thirds of the
patients were seriously ill with an
active infection did not actually have a
fever okay well so do we know anything
about this virus like seriously it's not
clear to me that we know all that much
more than we started with there are
certain things we know more about we
know that the death rate is not three or
four percent another story from
yesterday is that New York has finally
tested for antibodies and what they
found is that about one fifth of people
in New York City already have antibodies
for kovat 19 now it's good news in the
sense it means the actual death rate
from Kovan 19 in New York City is 0.6
0.6 of a percent which is a lot lower
than 3 or 4 percent it still means about
6 times as deadly as the flu and spreads
three times more than the flu if you
were reach herd immunity in New York
City New York City's experienced about
11,000 deaths if you were to if you were
to reach hurt immunity in New York City
which is about 60 percent of the
population and a baseline you need to be
immune to a disease to create herd
immunity to get there presumably if you
just apply the same race you'd have to
have about 35,000 people dead in New
York City in a given year about 53,000
people who died in New York City so you
have to increase their death rates by
nearly nearly double right
to increase by 80% in order to get to
hurt immunity so that is the bad news
the good news is that not as deadly as
previously thought if you get it bad
news is that in order for herd immunity
to be attained a lot of people would
have to die is in order to in order to
in order to get there so that's a little
bit more information in in the Andrew
Cuomo the governor of New York he
announced this yesterday he announced
the antibody results here was Andrew
Cuomo explaining these sort of statewide
results about 14% of the population of
New York State has the antibodies and
about 21% of the population in New York
City has the antibodies here is Andrew
Cuomo on this yesterday the statewide
number is thirteen point nine percent
tested positive for having the
antibodies what does that mean it means
these are people who were infected and
who developed the antibodies to fight
the infection thirteen percent of the
populations about 2.7 million people who
have been infected if you look at what
we have now as a death total which is
fifteen thousand five hundred that would
be about 0.5% death great okay that that
is a lot lower than people thought right
they were saying three to four percent
in New York City we just took the number
of actual diagnosed cases as the
denominator and you took the actual
number of deaths this numerator was
looking like 11 or 12 percent it's not
even close to that right 0.5% 0.6% that
is that it's a lot lower so that's good
news I mean the good news is did you get
this thing only six out of a thousand
people who get this thing are going to
die those six out of a thousand people
are likely to be people who are in their
late in their late 70s in their 80s the
average agent that's in New York City I
believe is around 63 right now but
virtually everybody who's died from this
thing has a couple of different
pre-existing conditions that doesn't
mean it's safe for everybody else I mean
I know personally at least one person
who did not have pre-existing conditions
about six years old and died of this
thing and I think a lot of people who
have friends in New York City know
people or at least know of people who
have died from this thing without
pre-existing conditions just because so
many people have died of this and then
we're approaching 46,000 people dying in
five weeks across the United States
during in an incredible lockdown the
likes of which we have never seen in our
lifetime this thing is still very
dangerous because
even if it is only five times as deadly
as the flu if it spreads three times as
quickly as the flu then if you just took
the flus raw statistics and say the flu
kills five and 50,000 people you'd have
to multiply that by a factor of three in
order to get to the death in order to
get to the case fatality rate and then
you'd have to multiply it again by a
factor of three because it spreads three
times as quickly among three times as
many people in the population presumably
if left unchecked so you'd have to
multiply it by a factor of two point
five two point one you'd have to
multiply by a factor of 15 so you're
ending up with over half a million
deaths easily from this thing if there's
no mitigation if people do not put on
masks now people will put on masks
people will socially distance I have
faith in the American people that they
will do this again the good news is it's
less deadly and thought the bad news is
it's so widespread and so in symptomatic
that the notion that we're ever going to
be able to test to the extent that
people are just going to be taken out of
the population if they have it generally
is not true you're gonna be able to see
a major spike if the testing is in place
and that's why you've seen people like
Scott Gottlieb at the FDA suggest
300,000 tests a day would be necessary
because that way you can at least have
sort of a sample size test in particular
areas of New York City they'd be heavily
located in major urban areas you'd be
able to see where the thing is spiking
and then maybe do some contact tracing
although contact tracing in a city like
New York is gonna be nearly impossible I
have no idea how you contact trace in
the subway system a good truly South
Korea has been doing this for twenty
years and they're fairly good at it Hong
Kong's been doing this for twenty years
they're pretty good at it we'd be doing
it in like a month
can you imagine contact tracing the New
York subway system incredibly incredibly
complicated there have been some
suggestions people can download an app
the app would immediately notify you if
you were within a particular area of
somebody because it's tracing you via
your phone I think a lot of people would
have privacy concerns about that but
even beyond that it's gonna be very
difficult to get people not to infect
each other if they are in close
proximity which is why the subway system
has been one of the chief problems here
so the antibody test has some good news
and it has some bad news
in other relevant information it looks
like there is another experimental drug
that is being put out there now
hydroxychloroquine has been I wouldn't
say completely dismissed but certainly a
lot of people are very skeptical of
hydroxychloroquine based on the studies
that are out there not showing
tremendous upside there was a study was
put out by China on REM to severe which
is that drug that was put out by Gilead
Sciences the study was
good and in fact the enrollment was sold
all day to cancel the study it was
published preliminarily without peer
review in in Lancet and then it was
immediately taken down so we still don't
know the results from that people have
sort of taken the early indicators is
maybe it's not quite the the cure-all
that people were thinking it was there's
another drug on the way I'm gonna talk
about that with you in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that if
you're not actively protecting your data
online companies and bad actors are
gonna get it they're just a ton of
people online who are looking for your
money right now looking for your credit
card they understand that everybody in
the world is shopping online right now
and this is why it's important to have a
VPN I can say with full confidence
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
and here is why expressvpn does not log
your data tons of really cheap or free
VPNs watch me make money by logging your
data and then selling it to ad companies
which is precisely the opposite of what
you want when you have a VPN expressvpn
has developed a technology that even
stops them from gathering your data also
lots of VPNs will slow up your computer
the expressvpn will not do this now I
run an internet company it is very
important to me to my internet speeds be
blazing fast expressvpn does not slow my
internet speeds something else that
really sets expressvpn apart really easy
you installed on a computer one click
you're not protected so protect yourself
with VPN I use and trust use my link and
Express with VPN calm slash pen today
get an extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's exp ress VPN com
/ban again expressvpn comm slash Ben to
learn more that's expressvpn com / ben
if i rely on it for my own online
security and safety you should to
express it VPN comm / ben go check them
out right now ok so there is that there
are several drugs that are in the
pipeline and are moving through the FDA
approval process and through testing
phase drug maker or Eli Lilly according
to a Wall Street Journal said it expects
to begin human testing as soon as next
month for an experimental Kovan 19
treatment that uses antibodies derived
from the blood of people who have
recovered from the viral disease the
testing could yield results by late
summer if successful
potential emergency authorization by the
FDA by early fall so maybe a couple of
months from now a few months from now
this could reduce the viral load and
people either about to get sick or who
are sick or even hospitalized and now it
really helped knock down that second
wave that everybody is afraid of in the
fall so that is some good news and by
the way the entire medical community is
on this thing so some people have been
saying what is the point of locking down
or even doing any sort of lockdown right
why not just go out and infect each
other will Ino
nothing is really going to change and
the answer is something is going to
change one of the things that is going
to change is that when you have the
entire medical establishment on one
disease presumably they will come up
with some sort of therapeutic treatments
that help knocked it and knock that down
now some of the other things that are
gonna change we're gonna have to protect
our nursing homes a hell of a lot better
again our nursing homes have been the
source of an enormous percentage of
death in the United States particularly
in New York it's been just awful nursing
homes are hotbeds for this sort of stuff
because everybody is inside because
everybody has a frail immune system
because people are older because they
really don't have testing capacity at a
lot of these nursing homes and because
one person bringing it in from the
outside can lead to a raging wildfire
inside the nursing home of kovat 19
Michael Goodwin has a piece over the New
York Post talking about andrew cuomo's
nursing home policy he he talks about
how the the Cuomo policy basically was
nothing they didn't have a real policy
for nursing homes
he says the letter was heartbreaking as
it recounted the death of an 88 year old
woman in a New York nursing home
it was also angry inaccurate about a
strange new policy that is fatally
wrongheaded according to the letter I'm
wondering who will hold Governor Cuomo
accountable for the deaths of so many
older people due to his reckless
decision to place kovin 19 patients in
nursing and rehabilitation homes I'm
writing as a daughter who lost her
beautiful 88 year old mother who's
receiving physical therapy at one such
facility the writer Arlene Mullen went
answer account examples of the governor
promising to protect the elderly because
of their known vulnerability she noted
he named his stay at home order after
his own mother and talked several times
about protecting her my mother is not
expendable your mother is not expendable
Cuomo said a month ago Mullen had
another complaint that the media never
even bothered asking the governor about
an order mandating the nursing homes
admit and readmit patients who tested
positive for the corona virus despite
the extraordinary number of deaths among
the elderly she was asked about this by
the post Bernadette Hogan at his daily
briefing yesterday and he said that's a
good question I don't know and then he
turned to the state health commissioner
who confirmed the policy saying if you
are positive you should be admitted back
to a nursing home the necessary
precautions will be taken to protect the
other residents there I mean that's a
crazy policy obviously the state already
concedes that almost 3,500 residents of
nursing home or adult care facilities
are known to have died from coronavirus
or nearly 25 percent of all deaths in
New York more than 2,000 of the total
are in the five boroughs so we're gonna
have to
better at protecting the elderly and we
are gonna get better at this stuff so I
don't think that the death rate is going
to be the same as it has been prior or
rather let's put it this way and the
infection rate is gonna be the same as
it has been prior when we say that the
death rate in New York City is 0.5 or
0.6 percent that is the death rate but
the infection rate is really the problem
in New York City that infection rate is
not going to be mimicked all over the
country New York is a uniquely bad place
for infection because everybody is in
close contacts enclosed areas and so
it's important to keep that in mind when
we talk about treating different areas
differently
and we should be treating different
areas differently when dr. Anthony
pouchy suggests that he is not overly
confident with kovat 19 testing
capabilities that makes a hell of a lot
more difference in New York City than it
makes in rural Georgia for example here
was Anthony Fauci yesterday absolutely
need to significantly ramp up not only
the number of tests but the capacity to
actually perform them so that you don't
have a situation where you have a test
but it can't be done because there's not
a swab or not an extraction media or not
the right vial all of those things got
to be in place I am not overly confident
right now at all that we have what it
takes to do that ok well he's right
about that but the question is what the
testing is going to accomplish when 20%
of New York said he had this thing
without anybody knowing about it it's
pretty astonishing again the question is
how much testing and to what end and
public policy officials are not really
being clear in what they intend from
this which is why there's so much
confusion about reopening we're gonna
get to the confusion about reopening in
just one second we're gonna get to that
in a few minutes but we have to discuss
obviously the big story of the day which
is everybody is mad at President Trump
because President Trump it turns out is
President Trump and says things and and
as I've said many times on his epitaph
that will say Donald Trump 45th
president of the United States he said a
lot of bleep right that's that's that
that'd be the nice version of the
epitaph oh yeah again I like a lot of
the stuff he's done as president I think
that he's handled the coronavirus
situation in terms of policy actually
really really well it's just that it
ain't great when you're when you're
rambling on about sunlight and eating it
we'll get to that in just one second
it's also not quite fair he didn't quite
say that well gets that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that
right now it is uplifting as an American
to see how so many fantastic companies
are doing everything they can to help
get us through this trying time I mean
really people are really working to try
and keep their employees employed and to
find new employees and to do charity
work so the people who are out of work
actually have not only a source of
income but sometimes food on the table
Zipp recruiter is one of our longest
standing advertising partners we are
super proud of the work they do today
they want us to do something a little
bit different from the normal type of ad
you're used to so here's a message from
them is hey right now we cannot be
overwhelmed we have to work to keep our
loved ones safe and protect our
communities we have to work to build new
solutions but for this to work we have
to work together at zip recruiter we
connect employers and people every
single day today we're partnering with
the medical community manufacturing and
food distribution to find the right
people for the right jobs right now
let's work together as if recruiter is
working hard to make sure that people in
essential industries are being supplied
that that businesses that are looking
for workers in those essential
industries can find the right employees
and on the other end of the zip
recruiter is going to make sure that if
you are looking for a job that you can
find the right employer in that if
you're an employer you can find the
right person to fill that job go check
out zip recruiter comm slash work
together right now and find out how they
are helping zip recruiter comm slash
work together that zip recruit comm
slash work together go check them out
right now okay so now to the topic of
the day and that is science science so
there this all sort of turned bad
yesterday at the White House after the
head of the DHHS or a spokesperson for
the DHHS named phil bryant got up and he
explained some good news right the good
news he said is that some white and he
may in fact kill the virus so we had
heard a study earlier this week from
France in which somebody in a lab turned
up the heat really high on the virus and
the virus didn't die but now apparently
William Bryan the undersecretary for
science over the DHS he says well
actually we have some good information
that sunlight and heat may help kill the
virus now by the way this does show how
stupid it was to lock down parks now how
stupid it was to tell people to shelter
in their homes as opposed to being out
in public
not near other people right is a good
thing to be at parks on beaches it is a
good thing to be away from other people
but in the sunlight you are not coughing
on other people you're not sneezing on
other people when you're out in the open
air there's a place for the Germans to
go as you breathe right there there are
lots of reasons to be outside well among
those
reason so that sunlight and heat may
help kill the virus so I'm like
literally being the best disinfectant in
this particular case here is the GHS is
william brian our most striking
observation to date is the powerful
effect that solar light appears to have
on killing the virus both surfaces and
in the air we've seen a similar effect
with both temperature and humidity as
well we're increasing the temperature
and humidity or both is generally less
favorable to the virus as the
temperature increases as the humidity
increases with no Sun involved you can
see how drastically the half-life goes
down on that virus so the virus is dying
at a much more rapid pace just from
exposure to higher temperatures and just
from exposure to humidity so they're
saying in seventy seventy to
seventy-five degrees with 20% humidity
during the summer with with sunlight
right with summer sunlight that means
that aerosolized saliva droplets right
you breathe you talk you sneeze in the
air the half-life on that is gonna be
about 1.5 minutes which is a lot better
than people have been suggesting that
this stuff was gonna sit around in the
air for three hours four hours that
basically could be walking around and
just walk right into a cloud of the
virus without even knowing about it so
that's really good news and it does
suggest by the way that when we do
reopen businesses people should be
trying to do business outdoors as much
as humanly possible wait maybe maybe we
can have barber shops that are actually
doing haircuts outdoors maybe we can if
you're gonna go to a restaurant instead
of just seating people inside the
restaurant if you got a parking lot put
some tables out there in the parking lot
and socially distance the tables and
you're a lot better off than you are
inside the restaurants right there are
things that this allows business to do I
mean this is good information and it's
possible that if we just tamp this thing
down for a few months that gives the
medical profession a chance to come up
with new solutions by the time we come
back okay so all that's good right mean
that's good information and that is the
real headline that should be the
headline I mean that should I'm looking
for encouraging news are you looking for
encouraging news I would like to not die
I would like my parents do not die I
would like all Americans do not die so
that is the real news well then
President Trump gets up and President
Trump who sort of speaks from a
half-remembered dream when it comes to
the science very often right he's sort
of he takes in information and then it
bounces around in there and then just
comes right back out but in a very
garbled form he starts kind of riffing
about that time that the the Germans
bombed Pearl Harbor
he starts riffing about injecting
injecting disinfectant and how we can
get UV light inside people now in a
second ominous flavor he actually meant
because what he actually meant I think
is not actually crazy it's actually
fairly well-established but the way he
says it
it is it like if you don't know what he
means there's no way not to read this as
he's telling you that you should
actually take Clorox and and just go
right into the or they should take a
ball of sunlight and just down it really
or that you should take a light bulb and
shine it up your nose or something like
it's it's a very bizarre statement that
he makes here and the media of course
jump all over this now as I say is this
an important story no it's not an
important story is it good for Trump no
it's not good for Trump because again
credibility and trustworthiness and
level head these are things that people
value particularly in an emergency time
in an election year now let's be real
about this Joe Biden is not sentient so
Joe Biden could have said exactly the
same thing the media would have just
ignored it and they made excuses for it
for Trump they won't do the same thing
that's just a reality of the situation
which is why Trump just as a matter of
self-preservation politically should be
a lot more careful about the stuff that
falls out of his face but here's
president from making the comments that
that set a thousand ships ablaze
supposing you brought the light inside
the body you can which you can do either
through the skin or in some other way
and I think you said you're gonna test
that too
sounds interesting right and then I see
the disinfectant or it knocks it out in
a minute one minute
and is there way we can do something
like that by injection inside or almost
a cleaning because you see it gets on
the lungs and it does a tremendous
number along so it'd be interesting to
check that so that you're gonna have to
use medical doctors with but it sounds
it sounds interesting to me well oh okay
we'll get to him clarifying at this
because again what he heard was probably
he does this all the time he hears a
piece of information the piece of
information is right when he hears it he
processes it it comes out wrong on the
other end right he did this with
hydroxychloroquine like people were
saying hydroxychloroquine maybe a
possible treatment for this thing and
then he
went out and he oversold it because
that's what Trump does he's a real
estate guy so he over sells things and
so he sort of comes up the bumper
sticker version of what he thinks he
heard and then he says it I'll give you
what he actually meant in a second and
you'll see he sort of tries to clarify
it even in the middle of this press
conference and the media lose their
minds over all of this I will say that
the the reaction shot of dr. Burks in
this is pretty stellar I mean it's
directly from Arrested Development I
mean it's it's it's pretty incredible
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
right now your business more than ever
you need to be on top of your data you
just do not you do not have the luxury
of being able to be uninformed about
your own business there's a lot of
uncertainty to go around right now
NetSuite reduces it by giving you
visibility and control with so many
critical decisions to make you need the
right numbers you need them right now
NetSuite by Oracle is the world's number
one cloud business system with NetSuite
we give you financials cash flow payroll
inventory and more all in one place to
have clear visibility and total control
of your business NetSuite customers have
the flexibility to work from anywhere
with immediate clarity on critical
information directly at their fingertips
no more guessing no more waiting make
smarter decisions with confidence
because you've got crystal clear
visibility into your numbers join over
20,000 companies who trusted NetSuite to
stay in control it would be a mistake to
blindly stumble through the situation
right now if you are a business instead
you need granular approaches to your
data this is what NetSuite brings you
integrated business systems granular
approaches to your own data receive your
free guide managing business uncertainty
schedule your free products are right
now at NetSuite calm slash Schapiro that
is any TSU ite calm slash Schapiro don't
wait get your free guide schedule your
free product tour and NetSuite comm
slash capiro that is NetSuite comm slash
Schapiro ok so what exactly was Trump
talking about well first I just have
just because it's hilarious I mean I'm
sorry it can still be funny right
deborah birx he cutaway shot to her from
the other angle well Trump is riffing
about whether we can inject disinfectant
and whether we can put sunlight inside
the body in some way is pretty stellar
dr. dr. burns who's been on our Sunday
special and she's got a rough job I mean
if you are in the Trump administration
you have to balance
let's get good things done and also
let's not piss off Trump right that
really is the balance I know a lot of
people in the administration anybody who
tells you that's not the balance is
lying to you that of course is the
president Trump is not the world's
thickest skin dude and he doesn't like
being publicly criticized
and so it puts the scientists in sort of
a weird position because yeah I mean
you'll actually see it one of these
scientists is called back up and asked
about whether this is is smart or not
and the guys like well we're not
actually testing it and then Trump is
like well the medical people might be
testing it maybe MIT maybe and the guy's
not gonna answer a straight question as
to whether we are going to test if you
can if you can actually just swallow a
UV light bulb or something like that
that's it's absolutely so what exactly
is Trump actually talking about well Jim
Kennedy has a good piece over a National
Review he says that Columbia
University's Center for radiological
research developed lighting that uses
far UVC that can kill viruses and
bacteria without harming human skin eyes
and other tissues as is the problem with
conventional ultraviolet light you could
put that lighting in public places and
you could mitigate airborne viruses that
way but it's not gonna get in your lungs
or the rest of your body it's not gonna
be put under the skin or anything like
that and when the president is talking
about how sunlight maybe that could be
ingested well again that is a that is a
botched and odd read of when you go out
in sunlight you have higher vitamin D
production production in your body
vitamin D production in your body is
helpful to your immune system it helps
prevent infection or reduce the risk of
infection but the media are obviously
jumping on this to suggest that the
president Trump is a dunderhead this is
their real agenda here right they're
very concerned with President Trump
being a dunderhead you'll even hear
Trump correct his own comments in the
middle of this because Trump understands
he doesn't really know what he's talking
about here like Trump has never admitted
he doesn't know he's talking about ever
right he knows the most about everything
from the from the Afghan lemur to the to
the the swallows the airspeed of a
flying British swallow like he knows if
you ask Trump what he knows about a
thing everything and everything there's
to know about it they're experts you say
I know my okay he's never going to admit
that but right here for example he
basically tries to correct himself
because he understands like I'm kind of
just I'm just saying things that I'm
sort of heard and like he walks it back
I mean he really does
almost played in sterilization of an
area maybe it works maybe it doesn't
work but it certainly has a big effect
if it's on a stationary object my
surface is the heat the hot summer and
whatever other conditions humidity and
lack of humidity that that would have an
effect so that on surfaces where it can
be picked up it will die fairly quickly
in the summer whereas in the winter it
wouldn't break so yes okay so again that
what are you saying there if you've used
it on an area that is what we mean by
using disinfectant right over you spray
it in in particular areas of the air
maybe maybe that helps right like what
he's saying there or make sense so he
correct himself the media of course run
with the first headline because it's a
lot more colorful then you had a
reporter asking Trump or if is
irresponsible for Trump to suggest that
people go outside no that's not
irresponsible that's actually what his
own scientists are saying so this is
where you can see that the media are off
the rails they're not trying to
accurately interpret Trump they're
trying to drive a narrative that
suggests that Trump is telling people to
do unsafe things now we already know
that right we already know that they try
to blame them for a lady feeding our
husband fish tank cleaner and now
they're trying to blame Trump for
suggesting that it's good to go outside
okay I'm gonna say it's flat out it is
better to be outside than inside I've
been saying this for weeks all available
studies show it is better to be outside
than inside if you have a choice why
because you are not in close contact
with other human beings and breathing
all over them in recirculated air this
is perfectly obvious this has been true
for a long time okay I'm not gonna make
any bones about that so here was a
reporter asking Trump is it do you think
it's irresponsible for you to make
people safe to feel that they will be
safe from the virus in the heat that's
not what he's saying he's saying you're
gonna be safer from the virus in the
heat outside then you will be in your
home and air conditioning in a small
area which is of course true and here is
Trump basically pointing this out is it
dangerous for you to make people think
they would be saved by going outside in
the heat considering that so many people
are dying in Florida considering
that this virus has had an outbreak in
Singapore places that are Laden are we
knew the new headline is Trump asked
people to go outside that's dangerous
here we go
same old group you ready I hope people
enjoy the Sun and if it has an impact
that's great again I say maybe you can
maybe a can't I'm not a doctor he's a
person is good you know what but what he
say I'll say it ok because the doctors
are saying it that being out there is a
study from China it found that a grand
total of two count them two coronavirus
cases were diagnosed from people who are
actually outside talking with each other
and they were in close contact outside
if you are far away from other people
outside it is better to do that than it
is to be inside locked in with other
people
bottom-line truth this is true about any
coronavirus by the way it's true about
the flu is for about colds it's true
about any of these things if you are far
away from other people and in sunlight
that is better than being inside and
recirculated air this is why subway
systems are really bad for this sort of
thing so pretend that that it's
dangerous for Trump to say this is fully
idiotic an you can see the narrative
forming in real-time now the broader
narrative is not just the Trump is
incompetent and terrible and really a
bad bad person and all this the broader
narrative is that Republicans are anti
science and there's two broader
narratives that members of the the
Democratic Party and the media but I
repeat myself I repeat myself I'm trying
to push one is Republicans hate science
and the other is that Republicans hate
human life and both of those are
absolute utter bullcrap Republicans
don't hate science and they don't hate
human life in fact many of us are trying
to look hard at the science and figure
out what the risks and awards are what
Democrats are trying to do now is create
this binary where if you are in favor of
removal of lock down and gradual and
responsible fashion this makes you an
anti vaccine activist or this makes you
somebody who is in favor of people just
infecting each other willy-nilly
of course this plays into pre-existing
stereotypes that the media been trying
to create for a long time which is that
if you are on the right then this is
because you are a climate change denier
and because you're evil needs a nice
science and you don't care about old
people dying and you don't care about
poor people don't read this is all their
pre-existing narratives they're now just
trying to shoehorn a corona virus into
it and it doesn't fit I mean this is
this stepsister trying to put on
Cinderella shoe it just doesn't fit so
now they're cutting off toes trying to
fit that foot into that shoe well get
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that if your car is
having trouble right now Rock Auto would
be an absolute godsend Rock Auto is a
lot easier than walking into a store and
demanding quick answers to things like
you know is your Odyssey in LX or Annie
Exxon's you have the exact specific part
as opposed to the generic part and also
it's overpriced
instead head on over to rockauto.com
they have a great catalog it's unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
part when you can just get it at
rockauto.com and it'll come to you in
the mail best of all prices at
rockauto.com
reliably low the same for professionals
and do-it-yourselfers why would you
spend up to twice as much money for the
same parts amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need again never been a better time
in human history to use the internet to
buy products you need then right now and
rockauto.com can make it happen for your
car right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
his box so they know that we sent you
again that's Rock Auto calm and write
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box and they know that we say we
appreciate it and we know our
advertisers appreciate that as well in a
second i'm going to show you how
dishonest the whole republicans oppose
science but the left is fully on board
with science nonsense is it really is
complete and utter nonsense and i'm
gonna show you some proof of it in just
one second first being locked inside
right now it requires double the
excitement it requires double the joy it
requires a second leftist cheers tumblr
not just one two you have two hands
don't you and two mounds why would you
not be using a second leftist here's
tumblr I'm not lying to you when you
become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member you get that second
leftist here's tumblr with Bernie
Sanders out of the race for president
the tears are overflowing daily wire
members get many amazing benefits
including of course the magnificent
irreplaceable incomparable singular
unbelievable an incredible lefty steers
Tampa you also get an ad-free website
experience access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
access to the mailbag and now exclusive
election insight op-eds from wang taili
wire members also get to ask us
questions during backstage you get to
participate in all access live that's
our brand-new interactive programming
featuring one of the daily water hoses
we hang out with you every night at 8
p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
that content is normally for all access
members we've opened it up to all of our
members just for the moment because
we're all hanging out together in
lockdown again become an Insider plus or
all-access member double your tears with
those two leftist Cheers tumblr daily
wire.com slash subscribe also it is that
magnificent time of the week I want to
give a shout out to a daily wire
subscriber today it's kyle Trapani a on
instagram who's out there on the front
lines doing his part to fight the global
pandemic in this picture kyle and two of
his comrades are opening a test date are
operating a testing checkpoint dressed
in their military fatigues protective
rubber gloves face shields and best of
all proudly brandishing their elite
beverage vessels the caption reads hey
band cheers brother it's cold to our
ears but warm leftist ears mitigate all
rona fears with our Air Force peers
hashtag leftist ears hashtag Air Force
medicine
hashtag corona screening hashtag kovat
drive through so first of all they're
here a second of all better poet on the
on the order of Keats or Shelley this is
just fantastic well done we're so
grateful for the incredible job all of
you are doing by the way just a quick
note not just members of the military
doing an incredible job all of our
medical professionals if you see
somebody who's delivering packages today
thank them seriously like an Amazon
driver stops by your house give them big
thank you because those are the people
who are continuing to keep the country
running thanks for the picture stay safe
out there
and meanwhile again go subscribe to get
two of these bye you get two right here
two of those things go check it out
daily we're calm / subscribe you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so again there are two narratives
that the media and the Democrats are
trying to push one is Republicans don't
care about science the second is the
Republicans don't care about human life
and they are they're merging in these
two narratives so the Republicans don't
care about science thing every time
Trump says something that seems bizarre
that is going to be radically magnified
not just because he's president because
I mean we all know he's president he
says bizarre things all the time
I mean have you have you seen the man I
mean like this is what he does but
they're trying to turn this into a
broader Republicans don't respect
science narrative which is patently not
true particularly when it comes to
coronavirus it is also true that people
on the Left have been really denying
science all the way throughout the
corona virus pandemic
for example trotting out the false case
fatality rates to inflate the statistics
on this thing like we knew those were
wrong from the very beginning we know
there was no way that those right there
being trotted out by the media
consistently as though those were the
right infection fatality and case
fatality rates but we kept hearing over
and over and over that the who to doubt
the who was to be terrible we kept
hearing that if you said that it was not
a three point four percent death rate
from coronavirus that was actually under
1% this is because you were some sort of
science denier it turns out that you are
the science denier and it's not as
though that was speculative everybody
knew early on that there are a huge
number of asymptomatic cases and when
people were suggesting that flattening
the curve was going to alleviate the
virus completely or that testing is
going to be a cure-all that is bad
science I have now asked the surgeon the
the former Surgeon General of the United
States professors from Stanford a the
head of Johns Hopkins epidemiology
department the the head of the UCSF
medicine department I've asked a number
of people who know far better than I
what testing is designed to do it is not
designed to knock the virus completely
out of the US population that is not
something testing can do and yet if you
listen to the media that is the
suggestion that you will receive and if
you listen to Democrats that's the
suggestion that you will receive that
science denial hey speaking of science
denial I get idiots like John Kerry John
Kerr reporting for doody face like a
mudslide in the Hollywood Hills
collapsing in on itself like a dying
star his chin used to be at least five
inches closer to the top of his head but
over time he has resembled more and more
Barn Easter Island egg and Easter Head
Island here he is talking about the
biggest threats to America I'll tell you
it's her own it's not corona actually
let me correct it is climate change
here's John Kerry being a science II
science man most challenging perhaps of
all getting beyond the pandemic of
coronavirus is climate crisis and the
climate crisis could not be more real um
even if you take the climate situation
incredibly seriously to suggest that it
is a bigger threat than coronavirus yeah
then I go no on that one then I go nope
gradual change in the climate over the
course of the next hundred years is not
as much of an issue as the complete
breakdown of the world economy mass
unemployment and hundreds of thousands
if not millions of people dead like in
the next five months that seems that
seems a lot worse that seems a lot lot
lot worse okay meanwhile speaking of
science denial I am constantly amused
that Chris Cuomo is going on TV and
talking about like how people are not
socially distancing and how terrible it
is when we now know that he broke his
own quarantine so I go to his second
property and he was yelling at a bike or
her outside his house also just gonna
point out that this is this is an actual
real thing there is a his wife is
Christina she put up a blog it's called
the Cuomo's corona protocol week three
says just as my husband Chris began to
kick this I was stricken with the corona
virus I spent a week in isolation
battling Cova 19 here's what I learned
and what I did to push it out over the
week and she talked about all of the
various things that she did um it's not
super Sayan see she says I decided to go
on the course I set for Chris of
oxygenated herbs I enlisted dr. Lynn and
listened to dr. Linda Lancaster who put
us on a path of natural remedies to
build our immune systems and it's
working for us I'm sharing this but this
isn't a debate if you think these are
far-fetched treatments think again I
went through tons of antibiotics for
Lyme disease this past year which did
not help eradicate the Lyme only when I
took a natural course did I get better
I'm applying that information to the
virus because I believe in natural
medicine which by the way one of my
favorite memes online is the there's it
a meme online that shows folders on a
computer and it shows before says
science natural medicine next folder the
open up is evidence and then empty
because natural medicine not tons of
evidence to support it as it as it turns
out she says we're all trying to find
tools to help beat this I'm grateful I
have the ability to research and educate
myself on natural remedies and then she
talks about all the things that she did
she talks about resonance breathing and
pranayama helping to expand the lungs
and then she talked about vitamins herbs
and minerals she talked about three sine
x daily three antivirals daily three
Kappa rest daily three okso non-toxic
quinine daily and then she made a liver
cleansing beverage with one raw garlic
clove one orange one lemon a tablespoon
of cayenne pepper a spoonful of olive
oil a crunch of ginger and a piece of
turmeric and then she made a big batch
of this stuff also she suggested that
she was going to bathe in bleach at the
direction of my doctor dr. Linda
Lancaster's reminded me that this is an
oxygen depleting virus she suggested I
take a bath in that a nominal amount of
bleach yes bleach so I add a small
amount a 1/2 cup of only of Clorox to a
full bath of warm water
why to combat the radiation and metals
in my system and oxygenate it that's
that that doesn't sound like super
sciency to me and granted I am NOT a
scientist or a doctor this does not
sound super Sayan see she also used a
machine a body charger which energy
specialist Randy öppet suggested I
borrow from a friend
it sends electrical frequencies through
my body to oxygenate my blood and
stimulate the healthy production of
blood cells to fortify my immune system
and also rebalanced my energy rebalance
the energy well I mean I can't I can't
wait to hear how to use leeches to cure
the humors like what are we talking
about here again this is not to suggest
that she is on the same level as the
President of the United States when he
just completely Boches the science after
having heard it then he spits it out
wrong
but can we stop pretending that like
failures of science exist only on one
side of the aisle for political purposes
because it's just very silly and the
other thing that people are citing is
this idea that Republicans are just not
taking seriously the threat to human
life again they're trying to combine on
the Left this idea that Republic
our anti-science and the idea that
republicans are anti life and it is a
stretch so for example over at media I
Tommy Christopher who is you know a very
hardcore Democrat he says forty percent
of Republicans say the threat from
coronavirus has been exaggerated
another ten percents aren't sure a
drastic difference from the rest of
Americans polled Yahoo News youa gov
poll published Thursday found stark
partisan divides on a number of key
questions related to public health in
the state of Cove in nineteen forty
percent of Republicans said that the
threat of Cove in nineteen was
exaggerated according to Democrats only
twenty five percent said sorry eleven
percent of Democrats said that the
threat of Copan nineteen was exaggerated
about twenty five percent of
independents said the threat of Cove in
nineteen was exaggerated now it depends
what you mean by exaggerated if you mean
that it's not a threat at all then of
course you're wrong if you mean that
people were saying for literally months
here that the threat of Cove in nineteen
was so bad that you were gonna randomly
walk down the street obtain it and now
your chances of dying or ten percent
then yeah that was exaggerated that
wasn't mean if you're talking about the
actual statistical threat to young
people right now in the United States
there's no question that the media is
anecdotal coverage of this sort of stuff
has created an exaggerated perception of
the threat of the disease that doesn't
mean it's not serious things can be
serious and also exaggerated or you can
say that the Beatles are a good band and
also overrated you can you can say that
things are bad but also the threat has
been exaggerated of those things and and
it is true that the media have
exaggerated the threat to your specific
human life from kovin nineteen unless
you are elderly or an or have
pre-existing conditions or I mean that
that is what all the data suggests to
suggest somehow that Republicans who are
more skeptical of the media than others
are simply taking the science to not
seriously enough is to ignore the fact
that the media have done a horrible job
on this stuff a really horrible job and
now this is being conflated with if you
are in favor of ending lockdowns if
you're in favor of moving beyond
lockdowns this is because you don't care
enough about human life there's an
entire article over at the Los Angeles
Times trying to tie together anti
vaccine activists and coronavirus
protesters the vast majority of people
who want to see these lockdowns ended
and people given the freedom to make
their own risk assessments the vast
majority of those people are not people
who deny the efficacy of vaccines or
stump against vaccines you're gonna be
hard-pressed to find anybody on the
right who's more Pro vaccine than I am
like seriously I've come out in favor in
California
of vaccine mandates if you're gonna go
to a public school for communicable
diseases that you can pass on to other
people
and no religion no religious exemptions
for it right I've come out in favor of
that because that is a threat to other
people write a generic policy that
suggests that you should not be able to
pass on a grave disease to somebody with
leukemia or cancer or to a small child
or to a pregnant mother I'm all for it
I'm very very Pro vaccine I've done
entire episodes of this podcast actually
in which I go through all the details
about vaccines to suggest that I am anti
vaccine because I also think that the
government is without data now moving
into an era where they are where they
are not actually making good policy
decisions it's just a lie and I think
that's true for most of the people who
are saying we need to go back to work
and trans people back in responsibly and
the key word there is responsibly there
are some people I'm not gonna deny it
there are some people who are like okay
this is not really a threat we should
just go out and willy-nilly do what we
want I don't think that that is even
close to the majority of people who are
in favor of moving beyond the lockdowns
the fact is the lock downs were were
established to achieve a goal the goal
was to prevent the overwhelming of our
hospital system end of story that was
the entire thing but lock downs were
never going to prevent widespread
infection of the disease not unless you
lock down forever which is not palatable
and nobody's gonna do it I mean we
already see our food supplies dwindling
we see the food supply lines that are
actually threatened right now so barring
that we are all gonna go back to work
and the question is gonna be under what
conditions we do as I've said now for I
think several weeks we're all gonna end
up doing what Sweden did the only
question is when we should start doing
what Sweden did and what level of
testing is necessary in order to do the
hotspot testing and tracing and when I
say we all agree on this you want to
talk about how things have become
incredibly partisan like truly
incredibly partisan all you have to do
is look at the coverage of Georgia so in
Colorado they've basically done the same
thing that they are talking about doing
in in Georgia
Jared Powell's talked about opening
businesses in in Colorado and nobody
seems to care because he is not a
Democrat meanwhile the conditions under
which businesses can actually reopen in
Georgia it turns out they're actually
fairly strict it is not as though you
can just reopen willy-nilly a governor a
Kemp's executive order in Georgia this
is just again it's media malfeasance
design
to target Republicans in order to
generate a narrative a narrative that
has a headline that looks like this one
from Timothy Egan over at the New
York Times how Republicans became the
party of death people are disposable
so is income for the pro-life party one
is more important no one is not more
important this is about coming up with a
public policy that saves the most lives
possible while also not destroying the
most lives possible lives can be
destroyed without killing people as it
turns out and it turns out that a lot of
lives do end precipitously when you have
great depressions but this is all this
is the narrative okay but take take
Georgia is a perfect example so I'm
looking right now at a document from
governor camp about which entities can
engage in minimum basic operations so he
says the gyms fitness centers bowling
alleys body art studios barbers
cosmetologist Hair Designers nail care
artists aestheticians all of these can
begin engaging in minimum basic
operations April 24th 2020 this means
these businesses can open onto the
public on a limited basis subject to
restriction so what are those
restrictions wouldn't that be the key
question wouldn't think he question be
what do they have to do to reopen here's
what they have to do the minimum
necessary activities to maintain the
value of a business establishment
corporation non profit corporation or
organization if to provide services
managed inventory insure security
process payroll and employee benefits
etc the minimum necessary functions they
they have to be able to allow people to
work remotely and instant and they would
they want to allow people to work
outdoors because outdoors is a lot safer
here is what they have to do as
businesses one if the screen and
evaluate workers who exhibit signs of
illness such as a fever over 104 100
point four degrees Fahrenheit cough or
shortness of breath so if you screen
every worker if the require workers who
exhibit signs of illness to not report
to work or seek medical attention they
have to enhance sanitation of the
workplace require hand-washing or
sanitation by workers at appropriate
places within the business vocation
provide PPEs
as available and appropriate to the
function and location of the worker
prohibit gatherings of workers
permitting workers to take breaks and
meals outside implementing teleworkers
for telework for all possible workers
implementing staggered shifts for all
possible workers holding meetings and
conferences virtually delivering
intangible services remotely
discouraging workers from using other
workers phones desks offices or other
work tools prohibiting handshaking
placing notices that encourage hand
hygiene everywhere suspending the use of
personal identification number pads pin
entry device
electronic signature capture and any
other credit card receipt signature
requirements to the extent such
suspension is permitted by agreements
with credit card companies and credit
agencies enforcing social distancing of
non cohabiting persons while president
on such entities leased or owned
properties
providing for alternate points of sale
outside of buildings including curbside
pickups increasing physical space
providing disinfection and sanitation
tools increasing physical space between
work sites to at least six feet okay
that means that everybody's gonna stay
closed again it's a lot of conditions
that's a lot of conditions nobody was
really able to open up but nobody
focused on the conditions of opening up
which by the way is how businesses will
open up under all those conditions
everywhere they're not focusing on that
instead they're focusing on how dare he
even say the word reopening it's a lot
easier if you're a governor right now to
simply just say you're gonna keep things
closed and then suggest that your
political opponents want people to die
if they disagree is what JB Pritzker in
Illinois is doing he says he's extending
the stay-at-home order through May 30th
well without providing a metric as to
why that is or how he hopes to restore
some level of economic mobility and
freedom in his state next week
I intend to sign an extension of our
stay at home order with some
modifications through Saturday May 30th
to everyone listening we are in possibly
the most difficult part of this journey
I know how badly we all want our normal
lives back believe me if I could make
that happen right now I would but this
is the part where we have to dig in okay
again I'm fine with the diggin in but
you have to explain how you're going to
get out of the hole that you have no dog
and so far many of these governors are
not many of these governors are not
saying what their expected expectations
are gonna be how many tests are actually
necessary when people can go back to
work under what conditions they can go
back to work that's irresponsible it is
irresponsible how do you expect the
American people to trust that you have
their best interests at heart when you
won't even lay out a plan it's pretty
incredible okay time for a quick thing I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today I will admit my
kids did not sleep well last night they
are it's you know being at home this
much interesting times interesting times
but I have three kids under the age of
seven that means my six-year-old woke me
up for nightmares and then my three
woke me up because for the first time in
like a year and a half he had an
accident and then my baby woke me up
because she needed a nurse so it was
just good times good times
well if you're looking for relaxing
literature for your children like good
bedtime literature and just great
literature generally the complete tales
of Winnie the Pooh buy a mmm it's so
charming and so wonderful and a moment
was such a talented fellow I mean it
really is pretty incredible
he went from writing these kind of Serio
comic plays on topical political issues
to writing Winnie the Pooh and Wayne the
Pooh has surprising depth to it
it tells one things that's really
charming about Winnie the Pooh also is
there a no villains so it's amazing that
he's able to sustain entire stories with
no villains just kind of with charming
fun and it's all character based
charming fun the the the movie is great
but the movie is not it doesn't hold the
candles books the books are clever and
fun and witty and really really enjoy of
my daughter is really enjoying my father
is a great dramatic reader so he's
sitting inside right now reading to my
daughter and and it is pretty
spectacular go check that out it's
charming it's right it'll relax you as a
parent it'll relax you
to read the complete tales of Winnie the
Pooh go check it out right now by a a
melon okay time for some things at that
I hate so on a Friday I have many many
things that I hate today so many things
I hate let's begin with Joe Biden saying
them stuff so joe biden yesterday he
suggested that President Trump will
postpone the election he said mark my
words I think he's gonna try to kick
back the election somehow come up with
some okay said he's gonna come up with
some rationale why I can't be held
imagine threatening not to fund the post
office now what in God's name is that
about other than trying to let the word
out that he's gonna do all he can to
make it hard for people to vote that's
the only way he thinks it can possibly
win this is not how the Constitution of
the United States works
he can't just put on an election as the
president not how it works it requires
an act of Congress to change the
electoral rules and Joe Biden is an
idiot he doesn't know anything about the
Constitution of the United States and
neither do members of the media because
somebody should have asked him the
follow-up question on how he'll write
Trump's just gonna say we're not doing
an election this year how is that
possible and the answer is it's not
possible but the thing is members of our
media don't very know know very much
about the Constitution
because nobody in this country knows
very much about American history there's
a story out of The Associated Press
today the latest nation's report card
shows eighth graders scores in US
history and geography declining since
2014 results that Education Secretary
Betsy DeVos on Thursday called stark and
inexcusable maybe the fact that all the
schools are out right now and people are
at home means the kids will actually
increase their educational capacity
because I'll tell you what they're not
doing much in public schools apparently
civics scores on the 2018 assessments
we're the same as in the last round of
tests four years earlier the assessments
were given for the first time digitally
on tablets instead of on paper they're
administered to forty two thousand seven
hundred eighth grade students in 780
public and private schools across the
nation administrators said that lower
performing students lost more ground
than middle and higher performing
students mirroring a pattern seen in
recent reading and math scores which of
course is not a great shock very often
low performing students are not
performing badly through any fault of
their own it's because they don't have
the same sort of familial infrastructure
that higher performing students general
they have the problem is likely to made
worse by the loss of class time caused
by coronavirus across all three subjects
a quarter or less of students scored at
or above proficient meaning they showed
a solid understanding of challenging
challenging concepts another quarter or
more failed to demonstrate a level of
basic understanding the results showed
so that means that only a quarter scored
at at or above proficient so one in four
students scored at or above proficient
and 25% did not even have a basic level
of understanding the VAS said in a
written statement in the real world this
means students don't know what the
lincoln-douglas debates were about nor
can they discuss the significance of the
Bill of Rights or point out basic
locations on a map only 15% of them have
a reasonable knowledge of US history all
Americans should take a moment to think
about the concerning implications for
the future of our country the score gaps
between white students and black and
Hispanic peers did not change
significantly from 2014 to 2019 the
average u.s. history score out of 500 in
2018 was 263 out of 500 so if you're
just taking baseline guesses you'd
probably end up in that ballpark the
results categorized 15% of eighth
graders as proficient when asked for
example to explain the significance of
certain documents and ideas in American
history history scores declined across
the board for white black and Hispanic
students the average geography score was
258 out of 500
the 2018 civics score which measured
students knowledge of government only
about twenty four percent scored at or
above proficient there was no
significant change across ethnic groups
okay why does this matter the reason
this matters is because we are in the
midst and that this battle has not waned
thanks to coronavirus of a serious
debate over what the country means over
what America is you're seeing a lot of
stories these days about whether
American exceptionalism has been tested
by all of this we are not exceptional
we're bad
we're cruel I'm ready some of these
pieces Bernie Sanders talking about how
we need to fundamentally restructure
American society a piece from a guy
named when over at the New York Times
suggesting an American history is a
history of racist settler colonization
and oppression and that America needs to
move beyond the unfettered unbridled
greed of capitalism into a new era in
order to believe these things you have
to be really ignorant about American
history like you have to be taught a
version of American history that is
context-free you have to basically read
a synopsis of Howard Zinn which is very
often what is being taught in these
schools you have to not understand what
American history is truly all about when
you don't teach American history in the
proper way when people don't know
American history when they don't know
the Constitution when they don't know
the Declaration of Independence they
start to believe that America is just
basically a bordered country in which we
are all trapped as a series of competing
interest groups and this is what a lot
of people on the Left would like I have
a new book coming out that is on this
topic in July what what many on the Left
would like is for us to believe that we
are not part of the same America that
America was never an idea it was never a
Creed it was never an ideal that we were
striving toward instead America was
basically a bunch of fuzzy words put on
a piece of paper so that people who are
in positions of power could continue to
oppress people who are not in positions
of power and that pattern continues
until today study of American history is
crucial and vital to understanding how
wrong and stupid this is it's also
often politicians just say things that
are utterly unrealistic and ridiculous
when Joe Biden says things like the
president will just push off the
election a cursory glance at the
Constitution of the United States would
tell people this is not possible you
cannot just do that but nobody knows
that because nobody actually has read
the Constitution of the United States
when people on the Left suggest that
America's unbridled unfettered greed
derives from its settler colonization
past that is so context-free it is free
of the
context that all of human history is
basically about people settling and
conquering and colonizing and that does
not mean that the sins of America's past
are not sins it does mean that to take
those out of context as though those are
unique to America whereas the
greatnesses of America are somehow
international in scope or just things
that happen it is a complete reversal of
actual American history means he is from
the left all the time he said this idea
that when America accomplishes something
its world accomplishment you saw this
around the marking of the 50th
anniversary of the Apollo the Apollo
moon landing right you saw that people
are saying oh it was a global
accomplishment no that was an American
accomplishment so a global
accomplishment according to the left the
Apollo flights to the moon global
accomplishment the vast rise from
poverty to unprecedented prosperity the
fighting of disease not an American
accomplishment a global accomplishment
slavery an American accomplishment right
anything that was universal and bad
that's uniquely American everything that
sprang from America and has provided
benefits to everybody else's Universal
accomplishment many on the Left want to
see America as an inherently bad place
and the only counter affects you that is
the disinfectant of true knowledge of
American history an understanding of
American history it's why the 16:19
project which is a bunch of bad history
put out by the New York Times is really
damaging is context-free history it is
why the goal of left which is to portray
America in a bad light has serious
implications for the future of the
country dividing us along racial and
class lines in order so that the Left
can recast America as a bad guy and then
redraw all of the American bargain
that's incredibly dangerous that's what
people are fighting against and this has
been channeled now into the coronavirus
fight because a lot of the people who
are who are protesting against the
lockdowns what they are saying is we are
deeply suspicious that there are a lot
of people at the governmental level who
are perfectly comfortable with rewriting
the bargain between Americans and their
governments on the back of a global
pandemic I've said this for a while I
think that that skepticism is warranted
I do not think that means that we have
to pretend that Izzie's is not it's
incredibly dangerous that we don't that
we have to pretend that lockdown
measures were completely useless
I don't know particularly in New York
City I don't think they were completely
useless but - when you see a near 100%
crossover in the Venn diagram like it's
a circle between the people who think
America is bad and the people who want
can
you'd lock down that starts to make
people suspicious hey and that again you
want to remove the political
considerations from this stop
proclaiming that America needs
fundamental change on the back of a
Black Swan event that is the worst in
modern American history it's ignorance
is a breeding ground for hatred of
America ignorance is a breeding ground
for that and so the fact that our
schools have failed so dramatically and
teaching people the basics of American
history is a complete tragedy okay
another thing that I hate today so the
government just continues to spend
inordinate amounts of money
the House approved another aid package
the aid package had to be done the the
Paycheck Protection Act had been
essentially exhausted immediately
because like all big government programs
that are rushed out the door it was a
piece of crap I mean it turns out that
they didn't have good standards for who
could borrow and who could not borrow
you at Harvard University getting money
out of the thing you had big
corporations that actually didn't need
the money getting money out of the thing
right and and you saw the same thing
with the Chara's Act I mean one of the
big disasters of the Chara's Act so this
two trillion dollar spending plan is
that there was a part of the plan that
made it so that you would make more
money on unemployment in some cases than
you would make at a business and people
like Bernie Sanders like why do we care
just get the money out huh just pay
people not to work what's the problem
and nothing working paid them you think
they want to not work but then you see
people like ALC who is campaigning with
Bernie telling people actively not to
work gaining you can't have it both ways
Bernie was like you can pay people more
to not work then what but people love to
work they'll go back to work with Mike
on and then you have al C being like but
what if we don't what if like we stay
home like forever like well like wha huh
yeah bro
yeah like well uh huh
so the cares Act had a lot of problems
with it the new bill also has many
problems with it it is four hundred
eighty four billion dollars to restore
that depleted loan program for
distressed small businesses one of the
big problems with these distressed loan
programs is that when the government is
handing out loans to basically fill in
the damage there are two competing
priorities here when we ought to
acknowledge them one is the government's
an unbelievable damage to your business
by shutting me on the economy the other
is when you come out the other side of
this your business may still be damaged
because the underlying conditions have
changed meaning there are certain
businesses because they're locked down
they'll come back right they're not
businesses that were dependent on
in-person clientele meeting in small
amounts of space for example
so let's say that you own a jewelry
business and the government shut you
down but most of your work was done
online people are coming in kind of on a
sporadic basis it's not like your shop
is super crowded all the time you make
your money by selling expensive items
you're probably fine right you go back
to work and what the market that was
there it's changed some because people
are not as rich as they were but you're
the fund of my the fundamental
underlying market conditions for your
for your business have not changed in a
in a severe way your restaurant owner
and you own a bodega in New York City
that can fit a person with social
distancing not like it can fit ten
tables you can fit a person or human
being once you socially distance when
you come back to work the government
providing you alone to keep that
business afloat is actually just a giant
waste of money the government actually
should just have said your business is
basically dead and now we're gonna pay
you to be on them unemployment for a
while and compensate you for that loss
but we can't float loans to businesses
that are gonna be unsuccessful this is
why I suggested that the best way to do
this was to have banks actually assess
risk in loans and then have the
government promote the banks lending
under these circumstances to businesses
that need money floated to them in other
words if the loan was a bad loan then
there is no reason why you should
continue to float the loan as this
continues there's gonna be a lot of
pressure for the government to continue
to float money to businesses that are
not going to be viable on the other end
of this because underlying human
activity has changed right that that
actually is a serious problem is one of
the reasons why we actually need to get
back to work one of the reasons we need
the lockdown standing we need to get
back to work is because we need to know
what the market feedback loop looks like
the way that you can tell which
businesses are going to be successful
and which ones are not is when people
get back out there and they start to
actually patronize businesses again and
then we need fluidity in the labor
market all the people who are losing
jobs in the restaurant industry if let's
say the the delivery industry is now
going to rise concomitant with that or
let's say that the the retail industry
is going down the online industry is
rising people need to be able to know
that so they can move from one industry
into the other fluidity of labor can
only be had when you have full
transparency and so what the market is
demanding of particular businesses
creating glue in that system is actually
not a very good idea but unfortunately
it's not just that glue that's a problem
it is also the fact that the Democrats
are now pushing for States to be bailed
out now if the state has
occurred some sort of debt on the back
of federal mandates and federal
recommendations and damage done by the
federal government going to the federal
government to be filled in is not a
particularly horrible idea if however
states are basically coming and saying
so here's the deal guys we ran up a
massive credit card like huge over the
past few years and now we'd love for you
to fill that in no the federal
government should not be filling that in
so Mitch McConnell said listen if you
are at the state of California and
you're running this massive debt state
of California has an enormous amount
today you're the state of New York the
state of New York has on the books 137
billion dollars of debt it is probably a
lot more than that because they've
unfunded liabilities that they lie about
California does California will sign
contracts with unions and then say don't
worry don't worry guys we set up a
pension fund for you and it's gonna earn
out at seven percent a year if I could
get seven percent a year on my
investments I'd be investing with the
state of California right it's just
nonsense they've just been filling these
things in and union contracts
understanding they're gonna have to tax
people and sell bonds later to pay for
it yeah with all of that said these
states are running massive deficits so
Mitch McConnell was like okay you
incurred new cost from coronavirus your
economy is gonna get hit you're not
gonna take in as much tax revenue you're
not gonna be able to fulfill your
obligations you should do what
municipalities have been doing you
should renegotiate your debt with these
various entities and pension funds
because it is not up to the taxpayers of
Kentucky or Texas to pay for this so
Mitch McConnell said this and then all
of the various left-wing big blue
governors and Senators decided to go
crazy on him here was Chuck Schumer
saying McConnell is being he's being
mean he's being mean no me paying your
credit card bill for things unrelated to
coronavirus is is not actually being
mean that's just called common sense
here is Chuck Schumer Mitch McConnell's
remarks are so far out of the mainstream
he's gonna have to walk them back this
is not an abstract concept their food
safety inspectors risking their lives to
see that the food that's produced to say
and so many others that are vital and to
just sort of give them the back of your
hand and say go bankrupt which is huge
paying millions of families across
America it's a position that is hard to
imagine it is mean-spirited
and Senator McConnell as I said he will
have to walk this back he should not
walk this back the fact is that if a
state incurred
that has nothing do with coronavirus and
now your revenues aren't meeting what
you thought they were gonna meet that's
just called you being bad at business
okay the and and notice the consistency
here I'm saying that if you're a
business that is not viable people
should not be floating you loans and if
you're a state that is not viable people
should not be floating you loans they
should certainly not be bailing you out
right they should pay for the damage
they've done at the federal level and
then you should have been fiscally
responsible if you're a state if you
have to renegotiate those kind of like
where does the money come from either
it's coming from states that are more
fiscally responsible or it's coming from
future taxpayers who did not make these
deals in the first place the money does
not grow on trees
but here you have Andrew Cuomo slamming
McConnell's bailout comments as well
that's not who we are
it's just not who we are as a people I
mean if there's ever a time for humanity
and decency now is the time and if there
was ever a time to stop your political
obsessive political bias and anger which
is what it's more thing to just a
political anger now is the time and you
want to politically divide this nation
now with all that's going on how
irresponsible and how reckless know you
but irresponsible and reckless is
racking up debt for years for years and
years and years and years and decades
and then being like oh look our revenues
didn't meet the shortfall how about you
bail me out that is the definition of
irresponsibility the Wall Street Journal
points out that Cuomo warned for months
about a six billion dollar state deficit
thanks to runaway Medicaid costs and
taxpayers leaving his high tax state he
sent him one hundred and seventy seven
billion dollars business-as-usual budget
on April third that allows him to borrow
eleven billion dollars of spending
exceeds revenue in Illinois JB Pritzker
proposed a forty 1 billion dollar budget
including nine billion dollars for
public pensions he raised taxes in 2019
he wants to make the state's current
flat tax progressive if voters approve a
constitutional change this fall and yet
he and the unions who own the Statehouse
have blocked pension or spending reforms
bottom line is that these states have
been irresponsible for years owes the
federal government by the way racking up
21 trillion dollars in debt on the back
of basically bullcrap and then being
like oh look we don't have enough money
no the answer is no states should
declare bankruptcy if they have been so
fiscally irresponsible that now they're
asking to be bailed out not from
coronavirus related decisions but
everything else McConnell is saying
the right thing here and physical
responsibilities last I checked should
still be a priority for a congress
people even though apparently it never
will be again and we're just gonna spend
money that doesn't exist until the end
of time and then a hyper inflate our way
out of it ten years from now or create
austerity renegotiations in ten years
which is most likely to happen here's
the bottom line you can either
renegotiate it now and be fiscally
responsible or you can reach it
renegotiate it later when you have a
bunch of people who are waiting on their
pensions many more people than now and
who are gonna be deprived of those
pensions because the states are too lazy
and the politicians are too gutless to
make hard decisions right now okay we'll
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise we
will see you here on Monday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20 you know the Matt Walsh
show it's not just another show about
about politics I think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else so my main
focus is our life family faith those are
fundamental and that's what this show is
about I hope you'll give it a listen